[Music]
and army in orbit Muse what the [ __ ]
submitted by ICU P I feel feet of the
old school band Jenna I let us see you P
the space corpse has been proposed as a
new branch of the u.s. military who are
we trying to stop scary that's not like
a Marine Corps it's a space Corps Base
cord that's scary to me why cause what
do they know that they need to protect
us from they're trying to [ __ ] shoot
down people from the sky instead yes not
I don't think it's aliens
I think it's other countries shooting
down our satellites and stuff yeah yeah
that's kind of scary
yeah but they're also reporting that
with you know theoretically if info
comes around extraterrestrials would
invade earth and this is for real that's
not in the artists on spank bank
theoretically no yeah it's a real like
it's a real thing so just so the
conspiracy theories are real which are
which which knows because the conspiracy
theories that know everything about
aliens is they got [ __ ] picked up in
the cow field by the aliens and then
they they got blood probed by the aliens
finger and then they communicate it
through their [ __ ]
sorry forgot are putting a finger on the
anus and going to and it's like EP with
the finger et phone home like do the bun
haunts the brains up here
aliens blenders are in the shape of bugs
have you noticed that yep there's a
reason for that what am i referring to
suggestion so many different in the war
on IET they all have but repeaters of
because everybody knows that our
butthole is the most sensitive that's
why when you put medicine up there it's
it hits you a lot faster than when you
eat it I just want to be abducted at
least once but you don't want to do that
you that you want to get hat you want to
get abducted well I want whoa you're
terms of abduction has to do with
[ __ ] I'm just thinking like they
just picking me up cause that's prosy
yeah but probably an interruption of
your life I'm saying if they come
would be a scientific specimen like they
[ __ ] probably talk to me they're like
yo so what's going on on earth well let
me just explain a couple of things right
because a movie contact know what's that
is about your vision who's gonna talk
about arrival arrival they're 9 those
are two different names so in
legislation has been drafted by the
House Armed Services Committee to form
the space Corps and so they're saying
that this will be a new branch of the
u.s. military
that would be under command of the Air
Force oh the Air Force already has their
own section called a Space Command
so Space Command would then be turn into
space Corps and people in the airports
are against this change because they're
saying that it will just cause a lot of
confusion a lot of delays and a lot of
secretive projects that they're already
working on so they don't like this yeah
a lot of people are just speculating
that it's like I think we all talked
about high school what if they're trying
to protect us from aliens we don't know
about that or it could be the whole
satellite thank you the branches of
military they're all formed like this so
back in the day there's only army and
navy army had a baby and then it was
called Air Force and the Navy had a baby
it was called a Marine Corps so it's
normal I had no idea I have it's normal
for new military branches to be born out
of prior existing ones I want to be a
part of time corps and do it back to the
[ __ ] future baby oh my god I'll be
the I'll be the coolest human being
because I'll always know what the next
cat fashion trend would be before it
happens you'd always be the weird of no
I mean like right when it's about to
happen so like you know that Shakespeare
time when they [ __ ] have the Krusty
the Klown thing or like the tights in
the [ __ ] leprechaun belt buckle hey
exactly you'll be the [ __ ] weird I'll
put that on like right at the moment
when it's hot thing because I'll know if
you know just go back in time and then
try to get make myself rich I would talk
to myself the hey [ __ ] invest into
Facebook how depressed would you be is
even you go
- time and then you're doing that but
you're still a kid you still can't do as
you go back to the present and they're
like well you should I'm back in the
same house yeah why are you a room up
any like hypothetical question like
chilling them own fantasy then also my
own fancy I can't even win what the [ __ ]
is going on here at the would you do I
just challenged it I do I'll go back in
traveling with a bus I literally have
told you what the [ __ ] they do what did
you do well [ __ ] both musubi good I
got debit and good prom with you full
[ __ ] Facebook you have got in my
space yeah and you come back here and
poor I know I got damnit
I just look at myself what the [ __ ]
happened my feet are not here anymore
like God oh here feet yeah butterfly
effect yeah every time you try to change
something it doesn't get worse you
laughed at a pun this is what I realized
I had a different type of mentality in
the butterfly egg we try to kill himself
and the water came up but it wouldn't
come up his face I stopped laughing
because he failed it even that yeah so
I'm gonna crack that life yeah I cracked
the black sky if you can go back in time
what's one thing that you would change
or which point in time would you want to
go back to and flat I think the thing I
would want to change about my own life
earning or just a tunnel and eventually
like which point in time would you want
to visit and why that time to come all
the time I know all my life
so one thing I would change is I would
take education a lot more seriously
loser so what would you start off first
grade or [ __ ] loser is for school or
high school like son kid in my knowledge
for which damn
at what point though we're just starting
kindergarten or middle school or just
going high school no refreshing I think
I'll start a middle school that's when I
stopped caring
hmm so you cared an elementary school
actually no that's a lie I think I
stopped caring and like completely by
the time I was a freshman in high school
do care it for a longer time than I did
so you're going back on your freshman
and be like just you got to get your
[ __ ] together now and then you come back
to play that's kind of hard to convince
your old self at because it's like this
TIFF you need to get your [ __ ] life
together why were you up
Miriam Parris and [ __ ] I don't know how
to say that like I don't know if I would
really want to change anything for my
past because you would be here with
growing up I always wished and prayed
and cried and like I just wish so bad I
could go back in time to change a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] Tennessee's emotion you bet us
and you what the [ __ ] now this point of
my life I'm like [ __ ] that everything I
went through kind of the reason yeah let
me paint a different picture all right
I'm going to save you right now
because what I'm going to do if I'm
going to take you back into memory lane
and we'll take you back to TIFF I'm
going to educate myself you're going to
go to the school beat a good girl and
then you're going to maybe go into
nursing maybe go into pharmacy maybe
lawyer one of those things right but
guess what you're [ __ ] miserable why
because you don't have people like us
around you you know what and it's not
really who you are you thought that's
what you wanted but you really didn't
want that because you [ __ ] went into
this work force and you're [ __ ]
working 80 hours a week you're miserable
you have all this money a nice car
though
but we're they're [ __ ] miserable and
you want to [ __ ] die because I hated
that so like just like you both of you
guys you don't even want to be in this
profession but then you're going to get
married anyway and you're going to spend
a lot of [ __ ] money in this wedding
if not Paris it's right here in Cerritos
and you know what the professor's very
good it's because you guys you cuz
you're from Downey and you mental math
luck in Cerritos College Wow what's
going to happen is you're gonna be in a
cafe and they do this ekc walk by with a
difficult and yeah then you're not I'm
not gonna even know why but there's
something that's pulling into that man
yeah but you feel like I should be I
think about this cow main very slowly
you're gonna realize you only were what
Mexican French one [ __ ] Asian friends
for some reason you don't know you just
want one my same gender there's just one
[ __ ] minute
so doodles that you don't know why I
thought this was too much work and then
she picks up chopsticks and she just
like I don't even know how to use it
[ __ ] already and then she goes
through the [ __ ] Korean barbecue
she's like I've been here before that's
weird deja vu no good yeah buh-buh-bah
is duty
haha coming to a theater near you no why
should you wait here i girl us here
that's why you could appreciate here but
if you've been here like that you can't
appreciate here you got ain't good you
went down cousin you [ __ ] met us come
back and you're like oh they're all
right but if you were up here and you
meet us come back cuz you they're
[ __ ] losers and you're cute hi
hundred percent screw man I'm going to
keep you low over here and make you
happy
see oh I erased your [ __ ] regret
didn't I
there's actually all reminds me a lot of
my uncle once told me um so he once told
me that I was like now cry later gonna
grow up unless my god it's a [ __ ] mad
yeah happy letter later you know what my
uncle tell me laugh now cry later no you
have to go what is your uncle tell you I
cry now loudly
I'll go Tommy I was gonna grab to be
like a really strong and successful
person because of all the [ __ ] that
I went what a fortune teller and then he
was like your other family members they
have a good they're not going to get
they're going to be beat you really have
it all right but you're going to be cry
now
but laughs later right now later and
that's essentially what he told me wow
that's pretty salty huh you know like
everyone in the family's tattoos is this
way I want you to switch the mask around
I tried that laugh later cuz that's my
Asian like dude hey guys thanks for
watching our video make sure to follow
us on instagram @ JK films to watch more
videos right up there
[Music]